I will do what i must
then you will die
Hello there everyone this will be my obi-wan
kenobi episode 6 finale video there's a bunch
of easter eggs obviously referencing a bunch
of original trilogy stuff that'll happen in the
future so we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos i will be doing full episode videos
for star wars andor and she-hulk when they start
in august too and because this is the obi-wan
kenobi finale i'm doing a special giveaway for
a custom-built lightsaber the people who are
going to build it created a special landing
page on their website for the giveaway that i'll
explain in a second but many thanks to onshape for
asking to sponsor this saber giveaway onshape is
the only cloud native product development platform
featuring professional-grade computer-aided design
and data management like these special sabers that
they can help you design companies like formlabs
dhl and trek use on-shape to design products that
we use and experience every day they function
kind of like google docs but instead of creating
documents and papers you're creating professional
grade 3d designs of products onshape is going to
have the custom saber that we're giving away you
can enter the giveaway by using the link that
they created for their website i'll put it on
screen here and add it in the description below
and they'll just pick a winner randomly from
the people who enter on their landing page
it's onshape.com emergency so many thanks to them
be sure to check it out and i will try to also
contact the winner and include their name in one
of my future videos really soon but just careful
for spoilers from the entire obi-wan kenobi
series in the finale if you haven't seen them
yet we'll be talking about everything starting
with the opening scene which takes place back on
tatooine with reva having survived and going back
in search for owen lars at anchor head it's the
same village from episode 1 where the inquisitors
that come looking for that rogue jedi who wound
up dying anyway and also finding out about obi-wan
kenobi in the process sort of setting off the plot
of the whole series this time reba looking for
luke skywalker even though she doesn't know his
name she just knows the boy that obi-wan kenobi
was trying to protect is with owen lars and is
looking for him to use him against darth vader
theoretically obviously it doesn't go that way
but at least at the beginning of the episode
she's still trying to get revenge on darth
vader still trying to find a way to kill him the
first scene of obi-wan kenobi and darth vader's
shifts is meant to be a reference to the
beginning of a new hope with leia's krillin
corvette like he's going after leia again this
time very similar shot instead this time it's
just from above with the way they enter the
frame instead of from below they also borrow
a lot of music cues from john williams original
trilogy music during many different scenes many
different pieces of music as well the whole reason
why he increases the firepower against the ship
he wants to disable he doesn't actually want to
destroy it but he's only thinking about obi-wan
kenobi like there are lots of force sensitives
on this ship it's basically the remnants of the
path as it exists right now all the jedi they've
been trying to escape most of these people are
just force sensitives or their allies the only
actual jedi on the ship is obi-wan kenobi himself
but even though he tries to kill him later in the
episode the whole thing is that darth vader wants
to capture obi-wan kenobi so that he can hopefully
torture him for a long long time like he tortured
the rest of those other jedi that are in those
stasis pods they do actually reference those
again later in the episode when opioid canopy is
finally talking to reba at the end of the episode
i believe the testing planet that rokin mentions
to obi-wan kenobi is the planet that he goes to
in his escape pod that he fights darth vader on
it's meant to be a brand new planet that hasn't
appeared in the canon before they just created
for this episode when he says their motivator
is broken they're trying to fix it he's talking
about their hyperdrive motivator darth vader took
that out to prevent them from going to hyperspace
and escaping if you notice in the background too
zoom and enhance leia is currently talking to the
boy and his mother from episode three that we saw
that haja built out of their money but helping
to escape the planet to jabim his name is koran
so a lot of people thought that he could be a
version of korean horn from the legends canon
because karan horn's father from the legends
canon had written on the walls inside tala's room
he's meant to be an example of another random
force-sensitive person who's trying to escape the
inquisitors in the legends canon he actually winds
up at luke skywalker's jedi academy so they could
wind up paying that off in the future at some
point if they ever actually do a series with luke
at his jedi academy back on tatooine owen and luke
skywalker's broken speeder that he references is
probably a reference to the v35 speeder that you
see in the background of a new hope they actually
wound up using that during the mandalorian series
and again during the book of boba fett a couple
times that was the more expensive land speeder
that the family owned and used together the x-35
land speeder is the one that most people think of
when they think of luke skywalker's landspeeder
completely different but he doesn't get that
till later in the timeline when he's a teenager
i couldn't find any special information on who
was playing this particular alien here so it
could be a surprise special celebrity cameo but
i couldn't detect anyone in particular's voice
the whole thing with the rest of the ship wanting
to continue protecting obi-wan kenobi basically
sacrificing themselves because that's kind of what
they'd be doing is more about showing him that
people are still fundamentally good giving him
more hope for the future like he's supposed to be
way less pessimistic than he was at the beginning
of the series it's all about his character arc in
finding a new hope for the future many different
references to that happening like they want to
push him in the direction that you see him in
when you see him again during a new hope they
also confirmed that haja does wind up helping take
leia back to alderaan while he's busy distracting
darth vader so he does wind up being useful
during the finale like this is the reason why
they brought haja back for this episode we finally
see beru lars is the same actress from revenge of
the sith like i said earlier they just didn't
show her in previous episodes i think you heard
her voice briefly it is also the same deal with
ewan mcgregor looking so much younger than the
alec guinness version of obi-wan kenobi like all
the actors here from revenge of the sith came back
but because all these actors have just aged way
more gracefully than the actors during a new hope
they look way younger even though a new hope is
only like eight or nine years down the road in
the timeline like those must have been a really
hard eight or nine years that they all lived
he gives leia tala's blaster holster and
is a sort of link to her future eventually
fighting in the rebellion running all over the
galaxy with a blaster in her hands so to speak
they wind up paying that off at the end of the
episode too where she's wearing an outfit that
looks very similar to the outfit that she wore
during a new hope they set up the big qui-gon
jinn cameo scene at the end that we all predicted
would eventually happen very predictable cameo
scene even though it was really cool to see him
come back with obi-wan kenobi speaking to qui-gon
again coming to peace with the decision that his
confrontation with darth vader has to be his last
and that one of them will have to die obviously
hindsight 2020 it doesn't go down that way we
knew that their final rematch was until the death
star in a new hope but again this is more about
setting up the qui-gon jinn cameo scene and him
making peace with what he eventually has to do
don't worry i'll talk all about the qui-gon jin
cameo see when we get to that part of the episode
later in the video most of his conversations here
saying goodbye to everyone is him referencing
what eventually will happen in the future timeline
with the formation of the rebellion like he tells
rokin oh you know you're a great leader you
should keep it up rokin's saying he's just
getting started he could always come back during
the andor series because during that series they
will show the actual formation of the rebellion
that's meant to take place about five years
before a new hope so just a couple years after
this so he looked the exact same like not a lot
of time goes by the whole thing with darth vader
ignoring the grand inquisitor's common sense just
falling for obi-wan kenobi's gambit is another
reference to the lessons that he failed to learn
during the prequels era that was what all the
flashbacks were during episode 5 as well to kind
of show us all the lessons that he didn't fully
learn at the time there are a couple references
to him being obi-wan kenobi's padawan calling him
master during the episode also meant to reference
what will eventually happen during a new hope
in their final rematch with him saying now i
am finally the master even though technically
he was also kind of wrong in that instance too
but even though after they start their rematch
we don't see the grand inquisitor again the
grand inquisitor is a really important character
all the way to the events of star wars rebels he
eventually faces those characters that's when he
winds up dying so he's going to be around for a
long time so they do more series during this part
of the timeline like during star wars and or he'll
still be alive also consequently because they
did not go after all of these force sensitives
that went along the path those characters will be
alive too during the events of star wars and or
when he gets ready to board his ship and heads to
the planet they play some more music cues from the
imperial march and when he says i'll face him
alone like he heads to his ship that's another
reference to both a new hope and return of the
jedi first one obi-wan says he's going off on his
own on the death star to face vader alone but then
also during return of the jedi when luke goes off
on his own to face darth vader in the emperor i
believe the whole thing with obi-wan kenobi taking
the lola droid with him is unintentional on his
part because it still has the tracker that reva
put on it and it's just meant to distract the
empire to keep them from tracking the rest of
the shuttle and help them escape so that she can
get back to alderaan so i think it's kind of an
accident on his part but also for plot reasons why
they had the lola droid with him also so they can
have that scene at the end with him returning the
droid to her you also notice that darth vader's
ship is a full-on lambda class imperial shuttle
which we see again during return of the jedi but
the funny thing is is that during return of the
jedi that was actually the first chronological
appearance of that shuttle like they created it
for return of the jedi but later comics animated
series video games used the shuttle earlier in
the timeline now this will rematch their interplay
probably my favorite part of the episode favorite
part of the series in general and i think that
this was their whole pitch their whole reason
for actually doing the obi-wan kenobi episodes
like wouldn't it be cool if we actually had them
talk to each other in this moment here it was kind
of like their version of the ahsoka versus darth
vader fight from star wars rebels like wouldn't it
be amazing if we did that but with obi-wan kenobi
okay now how do we create six episodes out of that
like how do we get them to this moment and that's
where the series came from in reality originally
they were gonna do an obi-wan kenobi movie but
that was long before they'd done the mandalorian
series it kind of pivoted to doing star wars on tv
so it felt like the obi-wan kenobi series had like
four episodes of material stretched out into six
episodes and some of the episodes felt a little
bit weaker just because there just wasn't quite
as much going on as you expected because they were
probably just working out from the original script
which is like a two hour two and a half hour movie
but like this is the whole reason why you bring
hayden christensen back as darth vader because
you could put anybody who's super tall under the
mask that has that physicality you want to show
him speaking as anakin skywalker with the broken
sith armor and like i said they did this exact
scene during star wars rebels twilight of the
apprentice even though i think that that version
of the scene is probably a little bit better i
won't leave you not this time then you will die
but you have to have seen a lot of the ahsoka
episodes during clone wars and their interplay
for it to really pay off in the way that it needs
to i think that a lot of people will watch this
knowing more about obi-wan kenobi and anakin
skywalker's relationship than ahsoka and anakin
skywalker's relationship so hopefully when they
get to the ahsoka episodes next year they'll also
find a way to have some anakin skywalker ahsoka
scenes so that you can actually have a version
of that scene too so that more people will learn
about those episodes then go back and watch that
version of the animated scene and it'll pay off in
the way that it's supposed to probably one of the
best scenes in all of star wars not just animated
scenes but any scenes of any kind live action as
well in a lot of the dialogue that darth vader has
during this scene with obi-wan kenobi they lifted
from the ahsoka scene during star wars rebels
and just talking about their actual fight like
the actual moves that they used obi-wan kenobi
regained a lot of his technique since their
last fight earlier in the series it's more of an
actual fight unless of obi-wan kenobi just running
in the opposite direction although if it wasn't
clear during this moment darth vader is still
way more powerful than obi-wan kenobi but obi-wan
is still trying to use all those lessons that you
saw the flashbacks to in episode five against
darth vader like you still haven't fully learned
all those things that i was trying to teach you
and even during a new hope even when kenobi only
loses their final rematch on purpose technically
you could say that he actually won the fight
because darth vader only did what he wanted him to
do like he made obi-wan kenobi way more powerful
giving him the giant upgrade by helping him become
a force ghost by killing him we see darth vader
use a couple new force moves that you haven't seen
before he just cracks the ground beneath them just
causing him to fall trying to bury him he also
calls him master again another reference to a new
hope when he claims that he is the master finally
even though that's not totally true the intercut
their fight with the whole reva versus owen and
beru lars with her trying to get luke skywalker
and there's no way they could beat her on a
regular one-on-one fight so really this is
more about them using the train around their farm
against her and doing the same thing that obi-wan
kenobi was doing earlier leading her as far away
from luke as possible for as long as possible
and the funny easter egg you may have spotted here
so when owned large starts actually fighting her
one-on-one he uses the same piece of equipment to
fight her that they used in the death star garbage
compactor to try and stop the walls from closing
this bar here they also used the same piece of
equipment during the book of boba fett recently
that was happening in most eyes so i'm assuming
this piece of equipment is just very common so
i don't think it was the exact same bar but that
would be kind of funny if it was they also want
to use all of these scenes to redeem owen lars
character a little bit and show that he wasn't
just this grumpy curmudgeon of an old man that
hated fun he genuinely did care about luke and
think of him as his son and did just want to keep
him safe rightfully so because they referenced
this during return of the jedi with force ghost
obi-wan kenobi admitting that he kept darth
vader's identity as anakin skywalker from luke
skywalker on purpose because if he had learned
the truth long before when he was much younger
before all this stuff had happened he would have
run straight to him and into the emperor's hands
unwittingly and they'd have turned him into
another sith inquisitor they would have done
the same thing to leia too during this series
if obi-wan kenobi hadn't eventually rescued
her when reva claims that she just wants justice
that's the whole reason for wanting luke skywalker
is because she wants justice against anakin
skywalker for the death of her friends during
order 66 the way they cut the episode is kind
of misleading it makes you kind of question what
it is that she knows about anakin skywalker's
identity and luke skywalker's identity i think
she kind of pieces things together and that's why
she ultimately wants to kill luke skywalker like
i think they wanted to show that she had figured
out that luke skywalker was his son that's one of
the funny things too like the end of the episode
she just goes off into the wild and she's just
another person that knows who luke skywalker is
like okay we'll just pretend like you're gonna
keep that secret later we obviously find obi-wan
kenobi has survived he's trying to hold back the
rocks but he's having more ptsd flashbacks to
the prequels and to luke and leia earlier in the
series their scenes from earlier in the series
and scenes from the practice lightsaber fight
flashbacks that we saw during the events of attack
of the clones or before attack of the clones
that's what all those anakin skywalker voiceover
lines are from from that lightsaber fight that
we just got done watching and when they start
fighting again he uses the same force throw trick
against darth vader that he had just used against
him but the real point here is in damaging his
sith armor enough so that we see anakin skywalker
hating christensen's face underneath the actual
armor and hear his voice as hayden christensen
anakin skywalker you notice that when he starts to
damage his sith armor you can hear his breathing
turn into the wheezing sounds that you also heard
during return of the jedi and obviously then you
see his actual face under the helmet this whole
scene is probably my favorite part of the entire
series like i said this scene is really probably
the whole reason why they wanted to do obi-wan
kenobi as a movie or even a tv show just so they
could actually have this one particular scene
obi-wan kenobi apologizes for everything that
happened and when anakin skywalker or darth vader
have you want to think about him says that no you
didn't kill anakin skywalker i didn't it's about
this idea that he spent the last 10 years trying
to kill what's left of anakin skywalker within
him ultimately unsuccessfully because the title
of the movie return of the jedi is a reference
to the return of anakin skywalker as much as
it's a reference to luke skywalker returning like
when he eventually tries to kill the emperor the
anakin skywalker he used to be returns and he
turns to the light side of the force so during
this entire period of his life though before
a return of the jedi he's been trying to snuff
out the light side within him the spark of
goodness within him the emperor also references
that later when he makes his cameo scene at the
end of the episode too you also notice that during
the scene obi-wan kenobi calls him darth to his
face for the first time i believe because every
time they'd spoken to each other in their scenes
together he'd refer to him as anakin skywalker
at least up to this point and i think this is
also meant to sort of bring this into continuity
with their rematchering a new hope as well too
because during that scene he also refers to him as
darth as well i think the reason why he ultimately
didn't go back to tatooine looking for him
is because he gave the lolo droid with a tracker
in it back to leia on alderaan so darth vader knew
that the tracker was on alderaan but he couldn't
really do anything about it because he didn't know
that leia was really his child he just thought
that she was just some other spoiled rich girl
the daughter of a senator so when obi-wan kenobi
then eventually went back to tatooine there was no
tracker to track him back to tatooine also there's
all the jokes about him hating sand like where
should i hide the place that anakin hates most
the place with all the sand then the way they cut
the finale the timeline is just a little bit wonky
like this scene of reva coming for luke skywalker
isn't meant to be happening concurrently with
darth vader obi-wan kenobi's rematch because
they want obi-wan kenobi to be able to arrive just
as she's walking back like they want this to all
line up but they reveal she's unable to kill luke
skywalker because she has this ptsd flashback to
order 66 seeing him as like another version of
her we all predicted this was going to happen
she would turn good somehow survive the end of
the series just eventually go off into the ether
and hide go to ground she might come back again
during future series we'll see but the whole thing
with obi-wan kenobi sensing what was happening
to luke through the force that far away is also
meant to show you how he's re-attuned himself to
the force which helps set up the big qui-gon jin
cameo scene at the end like i was just kind of
waiting for you to get to this point again where
you'd reconnected with the force before you
could actually see me obi-wan's talked to her
about finally honoring her friends is a reference
to all those other jedi that they put in those
stasis paws that they tortured that she herself
actually wound up torturing there's a little bit
of hand waving that goes over that maybe at some
point they'll go back and they'll rescue some of
those bodies even though most of them i believe
are meant to be dead but obi-wan is trying to
tell her that by turning good in the things that
she will eventually do to help other rogue jedi
other force sensitives that will help honor the
memory of all of her friends from order 66. she
also gives him her sith inquisitor lightsaber i'm
assuming that he either dismantles it immediately
or there's just one of those in his things now
but i think he probably would have disassembled
that one back in darth vader's castle on mustafar
they bring back emperor palpatine another cameo
scene they've repaired his sith armor and the
emperor's line about his thoughts being clear
on this matter is meant to be another reference to
the original trilogy but during that scene it was
more of a reference about luke skywalker that the
emperor was referring to like i hope your thoughts
on this matter are clear and just in general this
is a reference to the emperor never fully trusting
darth vader always assuming that eventually he'd
betray him because darth vader always had his own
plans and darth vader himself never fully trusting
the emperor always looking for a way to get rid of
him as well that's what he was trying to sell luke
on during empire strikes back when he was telling
him the whole truth join me and let's overthrow
the emperor that's one of the funnier things about
the darth vader emperor palpatine relationship
is they were both always kind of using each
other as a means to an end both of them wanted to
eventually find a way to get rid of the other one
and when the emperor says that his feelings for
obi-wan kenobi have left him weakened that's
another reference to return of the jedi with
the anakin skywalker within him like the spark
of light returning within him and him eventually
trying to kill the emperor so when darth vader
says no obi-wan kenobi means nothing to me that's
all done that's kind of misleading because even
though he thinks that he's killed the anakin
skywalker within him that's not totally true
and as the camera pulls away they play the
actual imperial march theme music again
previously there have been some remixes but this
is more like straight up imperial march theme
song all the scenes of leia putting her clothes on
at the end is meant to be a call back to earlier
in the series when it was actually her friend
pretending to be her but this time they highlight
the cinnamon bun hairstyle which we see again
during a new hope which is just like a classic
style on alderaan she's wearing gloves like she
asked obi-wan kenobi to buy for her earlier and
she's wearing tala's belt that she gave to her and
even though she's not wearing the same white dress
the white clothing is meant to look kind of like
her clothing during a new hope and i believe that
when obi-wan kenobi shows up this is the first
time we've actually seen him in a star wars
project on actual alderaan even though he's been
to the planet before like this is the first time
we've actually seen it happen he brings the lola
droid back which also explains why the emperor
isn't able to track him back to tatooine and when
he says that leia has already repaid him it's a
reference to giving him a new hope for the future
more references to that movie in the original
trilogy in the whole conversation with bail organa
and then later with leia as well the separate
conversation is meant to help set him up during a
new hope in their relationship during that movie
setting up leia's message to him she put into r2d2
in explaining why it seemed like she didn't know
him during that message like oh you have to
pretend like we don't know each other to keep
us safe he also references anakin skywalker and
padme again without coming right out and saying
that he's talking about them and they play some of
leia's theme song from the original trilogy while
this is happening then as obi-wan kenobi packs up
his cave he's decided to fully make the hut that
we see him living in during a new hope and goes to
visit owen lars and luke skywalker on their farm
he brings the model t-16 which he eventually
gives to luke skywalker we see him playing with
during a new hope and you notice he's wearing his
traditional jedi robes again that we see during
a new hope like he's wearing the jedi ropes again
in the way that owen lars talks about meeting luke
skywalker they're explaining that this is going
to be the first time that luke skywalker has met
him that he will remember and this is how he gets
to know old ben kenobi that he references during
a new hope i wonder if he's talking about old ben
like eventually they will cross paths many times
during his upbringing like he won't always stay
at a distance from them but he'll think of him as
old ben and probably one of the biggest references
during the episode saving some of the best stuff
for last when he walks up to actually meet him
and introduce himself he says the classic line
hello there and as he rides away and qui-gon
jin shows up they play some of the classic
force theme music so you notice when he does
right up to qui-gon jin here the entrance is
to the adrenaline waist this is where his head is
going to be eventually the funny thing about liam
neeson coming back too is that he actually said
earlier that he didn't want to come back during
a tv series he'd rather come back for a movie
but obviously now that was just a misdirect and
this is meant to pay off that whole scene during
revenge of the sith where yoda basically tells
obi-wan kenobi that qui-gon jinn is going to teach
him how to become a force ghost setting up a new
hope the one thing here though is that technically
qui-gon jinn never fully learned to become a force
ghost like he became a force spirit but he was
more of a disembodied voice but i think they
wanted to show him becoming a force ghost here so
the people who don't like really fully understand
the actual canon just understand what's going on
in this moment like oh it is qui-gon jin and it
really is liam neeson they got into this during
the clone wars episodes so if you want to learn
more about the technicalities behind this and
how the wills taught yoda to become a force ghost
with the help of qui-gon jinn they deal with that
during those episodes initially what happened is
that qui-gon jinn met the shaman of the wills like
the will characters here they taught him to become
a force ghost but he didn't finish his training
before he was killed during phantom menace he
could only become a disembodied voice and they
tasked him with helping yoda learn to become a
force ghost and then eventually yoda basically
told everyone kenobi well while you're watching
over luke skywalker growing up i want you to learn
from an old friend qui-gon jinn to learn how to
become a force ghost overall the series was a
fun idea but like i said there were a couple just
really really strong moments and then a little bit
of taffy pulling on some of the other stuff so if
there were any big easter eggs in this episode
that i didn't talk about in the video just write
them below in the comments and let me know what
was your favorite moment from the series i feel
like for most people it will be that final rematch
but what'll happen is we'll get more trailers for
the star wars and or series pretty soon in the
she-hulk episodes will be airing around the same
time there will be a little bit of overlap so
don't worry about that i'll do videos just like
i do for the marvel and the star wars stuff right
now too there's gonna be a lot of stuff coming
up the mandalorian season three episodes will be
early february next year we'll get a trailer for
that later this year too i've already done trailer
videos for star wars and or in the mandalorian
season 3 trailer from star wars celebration so
i'll put those links in the description below
while you wait for everything you can click here
for that mandalorian season 3 trailer video and
click here for my brand new thor love and thunder
trailer video with the guardians of the galaxy
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!